i never had money
so if i wanted anything i'd have to
build it myself
i want other people to be able to do
that
my name is matthew mac and taggart i own
vader body kits
we have a unique design car
that looks like a million dollars and we
produce it so that the average person
can build it for an affordable price
the best way to call this is a re-body
you're making a new car at an existing
car
we're cutting everything off and what
we're left with is just bare bones the
motor the drivetrain the frame of the
car
so you have all of your dashboard intact
all of your engine intact all wiring
it's just the cosmetics has been cut off
the car
my whole life i always fixed up my own
cars so then i decided i was going to
design my own car that uh i can call my
own it doesn't look like anything else
i'm extremely excited that a car that i
designed the vader is going to be used
in the suicide squad movie
i had built a car for a customer on the
other coast of florida while it was
there the production company walked in
and they said that's great it's perfect
you know it looks like a million dollars
and then nobody's seen it before
i think that it ties into suicide squad
because it's threatening when it drives
down the road
it's an angular open mouth angry car
seeing my own design on the big screen
is really exciting to me
the easiest way to put it is it's a
lottery ticket
i wanted to design a supercar
i can't draw
i have no design experience so i just
shaped it out of phone
and it took me a year and a half
seven days a week before i had a car out
of the mold
i literally had nothing when i finished
this
whatever money i had went into
developing this it was pretty much the
biggest chance i've ever taken and this
one just it's people love the car it
couldn't have worked out better
you